can you make a Christo one Wow I'm
kidding right I am now crystal that's
the most I've seen Chris smile before
and most Harris what's up everyone today
I'm talking to mr. Frank sheet and we're
gonna teach you guys how to create your
own snap lens and for the people who
don't know who you are Frank introduce
yourself and let people know what you do
sure hi everyone my name is Frank I'm
co-founder at paper triangles we do
immersive interactive content for brands
and we're also part of the snapchat of
official lens creators and lens great
partner program so I'm really excited
here to share with you guys a little bit
what we learn in lens studio and how you
can make your own snapchat lenses and
the reason why I'm bringing Frank on is
because we've had him on the show before
and I wanted to introduce you guys to
thinking about how to design and create
in a new space right so AR and VR could
look very daunting it's a new emerging
technology and has been for the past
couple of years but I think after this
tutorial are gonna realize it's not that
painful and it's gonna be very easy to
get into it so let's go in the other
room to check out some of the lenses
that Frank has made so this is one of
our client lenses it's for their staff
original shell called fan life
it's like a realistic band that we can
teleport into and we can see like what
that's crazy yeah we can see all the
kind of like things that we bill and you
can teleport into you know different
aspect of this you can see the front see
all these been in here that's really
crazy top and tough to go to this bed
area so you can see what's in here
and there's interaction okay so this is
like a ukulele it plays like an audio
wow that's really immersive I didn't
know that you have so many portals and
stuff like that and this is a poured oil
kind of like showing that and then
that's this is just for the show kind of
like building off of you know you can
see the deeper we got our deeper world
that the show is build on we build these
portals that kind of extend out so this
is the second one so this is called sky
segmentation so you can see there's no
real fireworks in the back but what it
does is cuts out perfectly where the sky
would be uh-huh so it's like a 360 view
of fireworks and it's like playing so
it's doing a sky replace yep so it's
like Queens Queens in real time right
yep yeah that's amazing
and then next we'll show kind of I'll
show another lens we did which is like
yeah yeah so you can like interact and
like this one called clients from hell
the titles but in the last time gonna
show this is a one of the kind of ones
that we did to prove the snap that we
were pushing the kind of like paw at the
platform because not everyone was doing
through neat portals at that time we
can't really bad move into it but so
happens it's like making this like
different world that taps and goes into
this vapor world aesthetic this is the
first time we did a portal on this like
photorealistic level wow that's super
cool too you've stepped into the portal
or the mirror there yep and this is all
done in cinema 4d and and textured in
substance uh-huh so all these tools are
pretty much available to you and you can
use any kind of like
softly posted that's amazing you
pre-built it in cinema 4d and then you
brought it in through synapse video lens
and all portals are pretty much like
that that's why we like how portals are
very big in the snapchat world this is
very immersive for brands to go and
engage and look around and it's enough
brands want the most section really
portal yes oh yeah I think this is good
examples for people to understand how
they could possibly use this or let's go
back in the studio and show people how
we can make what sounds good so we're
back it was pretty cool to just see some
of the stuff in a brighter room of how
Frank and his company has made all kinds
of different AR lenses in snap studio so
hopefully that will give you guys an
idea of the things that are possible
when you create and design in this place
[Music]
so when you go to lenses Knapp Chad comm
you download the software and you pop it
open you'll see the first thing you
notice are templates lends to you it is
a great job of creating easy templates
for you to base your project on so we're
gonna use one that's the most basic that
has no additional elements that only use
the tools provided to you by and last
video and the one we're gonna use is
called distort so when you open a studio
if you ever use any 3d software it
should be pretty familiar but if you
haven't kind of breaking it down for you
so on the left hand side is all your
resources and objects panel so on the
bottom is where you import your
additional resources if you have any and
on the top is our objects panel this is
where you import assets you know that's
already imported into the lens studio
kind of like perspective so you can use
as an object to use in my studio in the
middle is your perspective view this is
where you move around and
the your your creation in 3d space so a
lot of you who are views through
software will translate that kind of
language over but if you haven't all you
have to do is press alt and left click
to move around
you know hold middle mouse is zoom right
click as well and then W to move e to
rotate an R to scale that's pretty
Universal for most 3d programs so if
you've spent any time in any 3d software
you're gonna recognize all of these
shortcuts right away so now we kind of
get into it on the right hand side you
have your inspector panel inspector
panel really is the detail of each of
your objects so I selected this face
inset and you can tell that you know the
face region is covering its mouth and
etc etc so that will kind of go into
details in a little bit and the
right-hand panel is your preview panel
so this is where you can see your lenses
happening in real time so you can see on
the here that my face is distorted right
now I got a really big mouth and like
big ears big eyes right my puppy eyes
almost so these are kind of the panels
we have and let's do it and the really
easy way to push and see your product is
the press this button on top right hand
corner it's called let's push your lens
so what it does is when you press it it
will push to your phone so I'm gonna
press it and it will send the lens to my
phone for you to preview and see on the
actual true native platform and what you
have to do here is when you click it so
I have mine already linked so when you
click it it will tell you please scan
the code so you just press and hold and
they'll process and link the software to
your phone so now we can see we have
this lens that's historic on my phone ok
so we have it connected now we're gonna
try to make another version of this
disorder without importing new assets so
on the left hand side you have all this
kind of objective panels you can see on
the top we have the camera the camera is
what tells you that it's looking at the
phone so this is what comes with every
lens to go template so I would only mess
with things that says edit me and this
is what I love about snapchat it tells
you what to edit and what don't you edit
so what we're gonna do is edit some of
these deformers so on the top you can
see
all the effects that we have so these
aren't distortion effects so we turn
them on and off you can see you like my
eyes changing and then we're gonna keep
them on so I like this I one I like eyes
are always cool so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna take both of these eyes
where is to pull these eyes right I'm
just gonna make them bigger
I want bigger eyes I'm gonna topple
these eyes sorry you'll see this on the
b-roll but this is what this is where
the fun begins because you can really
see the light panel what's happening and
that's cool
well I'm like really really I'm sure you
can have a lot of fun with this endless
hours and this hour so now so I'm gonna
change this face I'm gonna show you guys
how easy it is to change things so in
here you can see we have a face inset so
what it does is it takes an image and a
recording of your face and makes another
one that's separate and puts it on top
so it's kind of like replacing your old
face right right so what I want to do is
I don't want to change my mouth I like
to not weigh this but I want to have
like more eyes so I'm gonna take this
and put it as my left eye so you can see
now I got a mouth but on an eye position
right so but I don't really want it on
my eyes still one on my left eye so what
I'm gonna simply do is drag and drop can
you just give yourself their division
and put it right in jail okay I'm gonna
do this so yeah there we go
Matt's suggestion so I have a left eye
Frank is enlightened now I'm in light
that's what we're gonna call this filter
dissing appellants look look at this
link right enlightenment right so now I
have three eyes so in that point you
just created a new lens with the
template that it came with you without
creating any new assets so I mean it's
it seems like Matt really likes his
three eyes you know it's like it's my
new my new thing it's probably creepy
for some people and I'm sure there's a
phobia around this sorry guys
so if you tell my glass is actually
better because it tracks your frames so
like for any will uses glasses take them
off and
see what it looks like all right oh
that's really creepy okay so I like this
I think it's kind of a little weird and
creepy Island
I feel enlightened and I want to push it
and I want to share with my friends
right so back to them back to lens to
you so to publish and share lens to the
community all you have to do is click
publish then on the top left hand corner
right so when you click that it prompts
to your my lenses panel and it prompts
you to share it it says either two ways
sponsored or community so sponsored
lenses are mainly for brand and brand
activations but for you guys mostly will
go into the community line so when you
click that it will give you another
panelist it's okay I'm gonna either
submit or update existing right so I
want to submit a new lens so you can
tell that my lens is called distort
which is the templates name and
underneath there's the lens tag and lens
preview what lens tag is is that you can
add a distribute tag that kind of
categorizes your lens so for example
this one I would say like enlightened or
something or yoga yoga or meditation
meditation there's a great tags and if
someone does search that there's a
potential for them to see your lens
right right so I'm gonna add a tag
perfect and then a preview is just a
preview of your lens so you can take a
selfie image and upload that so when
someone come across it in the community
Duns you'll see the video video of your
lens before you actually get to click on
it so someone can see if they like it
don't interact with it no no I have to
do after that
it's press submit and what happens in
the backend is that lens studio does a
little bit of QA and process make sure
you're according to the guidelines right
and then within a short second in a
second it will approve the lens and then
once it improve and King what our old
demo here you have the ability to share
so there's two ways to share it like we
had mentioned before the code which
under the share button your pop-ups you
just click copy and you can put that on
Twitter Instagram Facebook anywhere you
like and the last thing you have a snap
code which is what snaps kind of
Universal string languages all you have
to do is open up your snapchat
application point it towards the snap
code hold and scan
and that will trigger the process of
tricking the lens and then all you have
do is either you know use it yourself or
there's a prompt to say send to friends
and you can blast it to all your friends
and that's how you can share and
distribute lenses so yeah that's a quick
easy step for you to make lenses without
creating new assets with what's given to
you in the last video I think that's
pretty straightforward that's pretty
simple what if you want to make
something like a mask can you show me
like the super easy way to make a mask
if let's say we had made a graphic or
maybe even within lens studio can you
show me what that might look like if I
just want to make to me that's like the
most simple way to do something they are
the are the legs is the most common way
so if I made like a little mask and you
just show me that the quick steps for
that sure sure so masses are like a
toonie face paint right right
right face paint if we're using the
language of snapchat right so this is an
amazing thing why we love now snapchat
has templates so if you look at the
templates we can look for a face paint
template so we just open that up and
what I'm actually what I'd like to do
can you make a Chris doe one can we find
a if we Google search Christos face boy
can we put his face on top of yours all
right this is how I really want to do
this this is how it's gonna go this is
how it's gonna go this see you know like
we have all this amazing technology at
our fingertips and we're using it for
the dumbest things no this is the best
thing it is the best thing oh this is a
perfect straight on photo photo of Chris
oh my gosh see if there's an angry one
that's better maybe I'll do this after
if we can find an angry Chris photo
alright so when you open up the face
paint template you kind of have the same
layout unless you do you have all these
sprites and kind of like things that
they already made for you so you can see
on the paint here it's what it's
happening on my face so if you open up
bird
like a bird get a flower so these are
just different templates that they've
provided for you gotcha right so this is
all 2d so this is a 2d way of looking at
the face mesh and then they've just
dropped this graphic on there and then
when you see in the real time here on
the right side that's what's kind of
mapped around your face yep totally so
in lens to do what they do fourth face
paint is that they flatten everything
out to a 2d image so essentially it's
like a 2d image of a face track out you
can see here that you cut out in
Photoshop whatever and just replace that
you look so beautiful right there Frank
I'm gonna look at the lip weight you're
gonna look away cooler by working with
one one Chris is part of the story the
hell on import when you're gonna Chris
though you out
we need a like a fancy title for that or
tag for that just do it just do it oh
man
just do it visible get it so you're
loading the photo that we just
downloaded online Google search
alright this is gonna be fantastic um I
have no idea how this is gonna work cuz
I don't know if this is gonna look funny
or just like oh okay let's scale this so
uh okay okay you got an image okay okay
hold on and it looks super goofy right
now on the real time so oh my god okay
this is his idea okay yeah okay so in so
do we so if you look at so so what I
when I imported it you see how in the
issue here it doesn't recognize that it
has a face so you can sit mapping the
whole image right so what unless see on
the bottom you can see there's three
tabs symmetrical mode detect face and
reset point so what you always have to
do is click so what I did is go to face
face paint the one that they had the
face paint another template I replace
the texture with the crystal image as
it's downloaded from the web uh-huh and
that's why you have the issue because
they've recognized the whole square
right so since if you have a face what
lens studio does is that you can detect
that face and then crop everything else
and just put it on you so I'm gonna
click that dude wait Wow
that's awesome I'm canning right I am
now crystal that's the most I've seen
Chris smile before and most
so now I have a beautiful crystal you
know now I wanna you know I like that
and I want to share this and maybe scare
some of my friends so I'm gonna push it
to my phone so now that pops up on my
phone I'm gonna load it later we're
gonna get a shot of you sitting in his
office with that with that so now yeah
it's it perfect right so now within a
couple us he lives are really right so a
couple of seconds I have took an image
online of crystal imported it and just
detect the face accordingly and it maps
all the way to my own face and you can
see how like that's very good
I know it's a low fidelity low fidelity
but it we grabbed right it masses it
moves with your mouse alike Wow and
that's all done inland studio so you see
I didn't do any coding I didn't do any
sort of like writing or anything I just
told the program that there's a face in
this image please attach that image to
my face right and does it automatically
so I know we got a little goofy here but
I mean this is a very simple way that if
you were to design let's say if you're a
character designer and you're designing
mask for your character
you could already repurpose something
that you've designed and just import it
in as a 2d thing snap studio will do all
the work for you and map it um obviously
there's plenty of tools here to finesse
this and make this look really awesome
and for the rest of you guys who like
poop and fart jokes you could do stuff
like this you guys can make your own
funny filters and maybe you guys can
make your own crystal filters so let me
recap this for you guys if you guys want
to make your own snap lenses you can
either import your own creations or use
snap studio by itself then you can
manipulate all the different properties
within lens studio here you can build
and test and see a live version of that
within the platform and push it to your
phone and then when you're ready to go
you just hit publish send that out and
share that with your friends and
hopefully we can make this Chris doe
filter this snap lens go viral so those
are the the big steps hopefully this is
a good introduction for you guys on
what snap studio is capable of doing
we'd love to see your creations I don't
know the best way for you guys to share
it yet I mean maybe we'll start a
snapchat account just for this and you
guys can share it with us or just tweet
it to us at the future is here and we'll
get to see all of your guys's creation
maybe there's a little special prize for
whoever makes the most creative Chris no
filter lens snap lens out there I'll
give you guys something special so I'm
excited to see what you guys make frame
thanks so much for helping us out if
people want to find more about you where
can they find you yeah so we're on
Instagram and Twitter and snapchat all
its at paper triangles so if you follow
us there we do a lot of posting on what
we think you know about lens studio
about a are I will constantly sharing
other works and other craters so follow
us anything you want and you know reach
out go for it
hopefully you guys can learn something
today and go make your own like crystal
lens I'm actually really excited so yeah
if you guys like this content let us
know in the comments section below if
you guys want to learn more about arv
are just some of these new and different
mediums that are popping up for creators
and designers let us know because this
is exciting it's cool for me to see this
software coming to plate this platform
that I'm not very familiar with seems
fairly easy for me to pour it over my
skills let us know if this is something
you're more interested in learning and
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe if you value this content cuz
it really helps us out so with that
we'll be taking off and see you guys on
the next one thanks everyone
[Music]
I can't do it guys my god